laurent t on
comment ça va très bien j'étais dans ma
loge je venais un peu en avance et je
pensais à nos et et nous en chiffres tu
sais ce que ça donne nous en chine ça
fait 28 ans de collaboration thierry
632 émission 2700 heures
d'enregistrement plus de 5000 coupe de
champagne 11 kilos de deux boeufs 11 kg
400 filles baiser dans le public trente
deux plaintes pour viol quatre mariages
et un enterrement 300 invités partis
fâchés 28 procès et 13 coloscopie
on est bien qu'il aimait bien c'est bon
quand tu arrives là que tout va arriver
sur le tu veux pas dire se mettre tout
nu
ce soir c'est un couple ils viennent de
faire l'amour et la fille lui dit alors
ça t'a plu est fait non c'est nul
franchement tu baises comme un lapin et
dit maintenant tu peux pas le juger en
10 secondes
gimmick
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai bien vu leurs émissions qui nous
permet m
quand journée en compagnie de mon ami
laurent masi
et maintenant j'accueille yann moix
m
bayard enfin en soirée
en tant que noir la semaine dernière
j'étais un peu comme si tu te maries
telle église puis tout le monde attend
capable et sa femme vient pas et moi
tout pareil tu étais pas là heureusement
tu étais en corée du nord tout paris
s'est foutu de ma gueule en disant ma
ardisson est planté par moix voilà
montella cette semaine ça s'est passé
comment on corée du nord très bien jean
jeanjean sort ouais ouais t'as de la
chance
c'est pas un cadre tout le monde la
vraie clé dit je veux dire c'est le seul
pays où on est ailleurs en fait tu t'es
le seul pays où on peut on peut planter
thierry ardisson way ou en tout cas on a
une excuse de le faire mais c'est vrai
parce que pour trouver un avion pour
rentrer cela dit non même en erythrée
j'aurais pas une excuse de toi aimer la
corée du nord oui et c'est ce que j'ai
de repasser par pékin et c'est très haut
c'est très compliqué comment ça se passe
là bas on braque dans les boîtes à non
tout drague se termine par le peloton
d'exécution
alors rappelé à la barre mais pas
forcément pour toi pour la petite
coréenne kita qui était accompagné dans
ses impôts s'il n'y a pas de boîte de
nuit de toute façon il n'ya pas de bar
qui à quelques 6 mai pour les pour les
locaux il ya quelques karaoké mais
comment ils sont les jaunes abeilles
sont normaux thierry longue histoire
d'amour ils pleurent ils sont joyeux ils
ont des en dix ans la télé oui bien sûr
il ya que deux chaînes me dont la télé
mais vous savez sous de gaulle en avait
que deux chaînes aussi c'est pas plus
mal 13 du malheur il n'ya pas les
réseaux sociaux ça nettoie pas de
portable pendant une semaine pas
d'internet je suis reposé ça doit te
voir oui ça se voit et c'est très envie
d'acheter un petit drapeau jaune angers
le badge que tous les citoyens
nord-coréen porte alors évidemment les
journalistes mal informés vont croire
que celui qui porte ce badge soutient le
régime non je porte exactement le même
base que tout nord-coréen qui habite sur
place puisque tf1 ils ne peuvent habiter
que sur cet appareil qui font des
offrandes de fleurs là bas aux
dirigeants oui alors il ya deux espèces
de fleurs la balle à kim il sung hye ja
de timmins hung et la kim jong il ya kim
jong il à ce à quoi les gars le festival
des fleurs d'ailleurs je t invite en
février grande exposition de ces deux là
bas ça y est non ça ne me rend pas
largement pro ma vie pour maryse aux
règles et aux mobiles en 2023 je parlais
maison on a le droit de faire des vannes
à vannes on s'est un peu choquant oui
mais filer en français c'est plus sûr
d'accord
donc maintenant c'est l'heure des
récompenses qu'on n'aimerait pas
recevoir en fait qu'on pense qu'ils
peuvent faire mal c'est l'heure des
matches d'or
[Musique]
m
merci
or seule chez moi de hors jeu comme une
odeur de brûlé mais moi je dors de l'aco
réalité à gérard depardieu qui en fait
sur place s'est comporté quasiment comme
un nouveau grand leader il a réussi à
lui seul par sa personnalité c'était
pantagruel kenyan gang a fissuré le
logiciel nord-coréen il sait en passe et
des guides il a dragué des interprètes
magnifiques tout ce qu'on n'a pas le
droit de faire depuis 70 ans non
seulement il l'a fait mais il a fait
toute la journée et je crois que il a
réussi à modifier le réel comme jamais
personne n'avait su le faire depuis 1950
et je crois que là bas quelque chose
dans les lois de la physique ont été
modifiées par sa présence à moi je dors
donc pour gérard depardieu c'est le
premier match de la saison le deuxième
c'est pour alexandre de nahla emmanuel
macron petit étriqué pays qui est la
france vous êtes en corée du nord dans
un ailleurs total sur une autre planète
vous revenez salué quelques terriens et
là vous voyez que clochemerle continue
petite histoire de cornecul où on a une
sorte de prototype nouveau en france
c'est le mélange de keira et des
marquises hauts fonctionnaires jeudi par
à cascais et procédant keira serait-
donc et une caillera ou un gars les
énarques calaisis barque maintenant des
expressions y va donc un mélange de
caméras et de hauts fonctionnaires qui
décide tout d'un coup d'être aussi
important que un énarque accompli et ce
qui est drôle c'est que ça va dans les
deux sens d'ailleurs vous avez vu que
ils ne respectent pas les serveurs vont
toujours l'obsession chez les cailleras
du respect au respect reste à gérer est
ce qui est très drôle c'est que le
mouvement est ascendant ça va de la
caillera vers le haut fonctionnaire mais
il est descendant aussi c'est à dire que
ça va du président la république vers la
caméra car quand mais emmanuel macron
dit qu'ils viennent le chercher s'ils
veulent un responsable il est deux
enfants qui viennent le chercher il se
comporte comme un type du neuf cube est
donc de toute façon je crois que là il y
à un mélange inédit dans la république
française que celui qui met sa casquette
à l'envers peut un jour se retrouver au
lieutenant colonel
alors ça fait deux mois que d'or le
troisième je comprends pas pourquoi les
bleus pourquoi l'équipe de france qui
nous a rendu tellement fier fier mais
alors ça résume absolument tout le mal
français c'est à dire que lorsqu'on
gagne on se comporte exactement comme
lorsqu'on perd c'est gagner en france
c'est perdre à l'envers les types gagne
le mondial et pour faire la fête d'abord
ils détruisent des champs elysées c'est
les bases et ensuite ils vont à miami au
mieux de prostituées et avec un truc
très symbolique de la france plutôt que
de faire mousser le champagne est de
faire exploser le bouchon vers le ciel
comme on fait pour le bol d'or pour le
24 heures du mans en classe de forme
leur la formule 1 eh bien ils rentrent
ils vident des bouteilles à 1000 euros
sur le sol et ça c'est exactement
français on gagne et le champagne fini
sur le sol on baisse le goulot c'est
toujours le mouvement descendant qu'on a
de maiko de macron du présent république
vers la caillera est là la victoire se
fait en baissant et je trouve que la
france et sa sylvain tesson l'a bien
décrit c'est un pays dans lesquels des
gens au paradis secret en enfer parce
qu'ils se la font tout seuls l'enfer oh
la la
vous savez que pendant notre absence
j'ai été invité dans on n'est pas couché
l'émission de laurent ruquier donc avec
votre successeur mais ce consigny mais
alors je suis désolé de le dire mais
christine angot était exemplaire avec
moi à mais peut-être qu'elle est folle
d'une façon sélective je sais pas
on attend c'est l'heure du débat de la
semaine c'est la belle terre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
demain
voilà la battle débat haut débit avec ce
soir fait isabelle mohamed saïd ahamada
et alexandre de lait chaud
les abonnements à m bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste militant et président de
l'association droit de cité bienvenue
parmi nous saïd ahamada bonsoir j'ai
dégusté l'envi comme des bouches du
rhône bienvenue parmi nous un exemple de
vertu au bon choix les spots
éditorialiste au figaro et au figaro
magazine bienvenue parmi nous alors
battle de ce choix réorganisés l'islam
pour éradiquer l'islamisme est ce la
solution miracle ou de la poudre aux
yeux mais d'abord l'édito de blake au
magnéto serge
[Musique]
dans son dernier rapport hakim el karoui
dénonce l' influence grandissante des
islamistes dans notre pays ils ne
représentent qu'une minorité des six
millions de musulmans plus vite en
france meilleure affluence est devenue
considérable et bien cela nous motive
combien de salafistes
activistes 50000 et sympathisants
globalement sympathisants de 300 milles
et des gens qui suivent les contenus
religieux des salafistes on l'aimé a
mesuré par les réseaux sociaux on est
autour d'un million en france la
propagande islamiste s'infiltrent par
les réseaux sociaux vous allez sur
internet sur les réseaux sociaux vous
tapez islam vous tapez ramadan vous
tapez halal vous allez tomber sur des
sites salafistes dans 90% des cartes sur
facebook les cent pages les plus
visitées sur l'islam sont favorables aux
islamistes sur twitter cinq saoudiens
figurant dans le top 15 mondial des
influenceurs politique et plus suivis et
bien sûr tous leurs prêches sont
traduites en français là alors voilà
pourquoi çà et là résultat selon une
enquête menée auprès de 15 mille
musulmans 28% d'entre eux contestent les
valeurs de la république au nom de
l'islam est pire chez les moins de 25
ans ils sont carrément 50% l'islamisme
constitue donc une grave menace pour
l'unité de la france ce que disait
hassan el banna le fondateur des frères
musulmans le coran est notre
constitution l'islam est la solution
c'est ça qu'ils veulent faire le halal
n'est plus seulement une norme
alimentaire soyons fiers de manger
france est fière de manger halal qu'ils
s'étendent désormais à tout le quotidien
il y à des sites de rencontres à la
halle le site de rencontres par
affinités quelques rennes du covoiturage
à la halle des sites de vacances halal
bref tout se met en place pour que les
musulmans puissent vivre en france selon
leurs propres règles comme séparée du
reste de la société l'objectif des
islamistes d'abord et avant tout c'est
pas d'islamiser l'europe contrairement à
faire croître ses d'islamiser ou
d'islamistes is et les musulmans le
problème c'est qu'en soit islamiste on
n'entend pas s'exprimer la majorité
silencieuse des musulmans bien intégrés
pour représenter cette majorité
silencieuse el karoui veut donc créer
une association musulmane de l'islam de
france une institution indépendante des
pays étrangers qui seraient financés par
une taxe sur les produits halal elles
formeraient les imams et contrôlerait
les mosquées et pour bien prouver que la
france mais musulman et le cas où il
veut aussi développer l'enseignement de
l'arabe à l'école strode en plus ça
éviterait que les jeunes musulmans
apprennent l'arabe dans les mosquées qui
les exposent à l'affluence islamistes
mais dans un pays laïc comme la france
est ce que c'est vraiment le rôle de
l'état d'organiser la religion voilà
c'était les listes de blacko mise en
image de julien grappes on commence avec
la réorganisation de l'islam de france
hakim el karoui veut en finir avec le
cfcm et l'uojf et mettre en place une
association musulmane pour l'islam de
france une seule autorité incontestable
pour la totalité des musulmans de notre
pays mais ça pose un problème paysanne
ya pas un islam de france y'a pas un
islam de france mais comme vous l'avez
dit vous-même à l'instant et comme c'est
énorme a nié tout juste avant hakim
el-karoui veut est ce que ça veut dire
que parce que hakim el karoui the et
musulmans oui voilà ensuite un islam de
france est ce qu'on demande par exemple
aux juifs français de vivre un judaïsme
de france n'ont évidemment non je pense
que c'est une atteinte au principe de
laïcité et qu'on demande aujourd'hui une
espèce de mise sous tutelle du culte
musulman pour moi ça relève de la
gestion indigéniste vide approche
coloniale de la gestion et des cercles à
vous êtes sur la position d'apple a
écrit le délégué général du cfcm qui 17
aux musulmans de s'occuper de leur
religion pas à l'état de l'organiser
c'est une gestion dit-il indigéniste on
jette sur cette ligne alors en fait
parfaitement d'accord avec cette
position là et c'est que les musulmans
sont assez grands pour s'organiser on
est assez grand pour s'organiser on va
s'organiser on est tombé dans un piège
comme on est en train de s'organiser
pourquoi ils n'ont pas fait jusqu'à
maintenant on l'a pas fait qu on demande
au culte musulman d'organiser les autres
cultes ont géré sur plusieurs siècles il
faut du temps il faut de la
restructuration le cfcm créé par nicolas
sarkozy en 2003 alors je ne sais pas une
attaque personnelle que je vais faire
mais sur la sur la structure en
elle-même elle souffre d'un manque
criant de légitimité auprès des
communautés musulmanes le cfcm ne peut
pas représenter le quelques musulmans
aujourd'hui qui peut représenter de
jugement aujourd'hui il faut qu'à une
plateforme participative qui inclut
l'ensemble des courants des musulmans on
n'y a pas un islam en france et il va
falloir aussi prendre en compte le fait
que si moi je le pratique d'une façon
mon voisin il fera qu'ils pratiquent pas
forcément d'une autre façon il faut
prendre en compte l'ensemble et décrira
les décors et sa non
pas vous étonner mais moi l'année ce que
je fais c'est que il ya aujourd'hui
énormément de français de confession
musulmane qui souhaite que
l'organisation soit plus efficiente plus
efficace surtout qu'on a mené des
auditions avec quelques collègues
parlementaires ces quelques mois et je
n'ai pas rencontré un seul responsable
religieux qui mais dis moi je suis
satisfait de la manière dont le culte
musulman est organisé en france dont les
choses se passent il n'y a plus rien à
faire plus rien à toucher in apple là où
je suis d'accord avec ma collègue c'est
que ce n'est pas l'état de l'organiser
par contre l'état lui sa responsabilité
c'est de aider des français aujourd'hui
ils sont quand même 6 millions qui
émettent le souhait d'être mieux
organisé et que l'état les y aide parce
que c'est une demande qu'ils sont
français qu'on est nous et moi en
l'occurrence représentant aussi de la
nation et de cette partie de la
population aussi et que donc ma
responsabilité aussi comme celle de
l'exécutif c'est de faire en sorte que
ces musulmans français se sentent bien
dans la république française un exemple
moi je pense que le rôle de l'état c'est
de faire respecter les lois de la
république pour tout le monde donc je
suis contre le fait qu'ils signent et
c'est effectivement dans la religion je
pense que ce serait affaiblir la laïcité
ouvrir la porte à une forme de
clientélisme qu'on connaît déjà par
contre j'ai pas d'accord avec madame
quant à 10 il faut laisser tous les
pourront pratiquer comme ils le
souhaitent quand des courants sont
absolument contraires aux valeurs
françaises est absolument contraire à
notre culture l'état doit frapper fort
et faire respecter la loi qu'est ce que
c'est que cet état qui dit bah
finalement les enfants apprennent
l'arabe dans les mosquées ils sont
soumis à des prédicateurs islamistes on
va la prendre à l'école non aussi et
sont soumis à des prédicateurs
islamistes il faut fermer ces mosquées
la renvoyer ces prédicateurs chez eux
yann là où l'état peut intervenir c'est
simplement sur une chose c'est pas sur
la parole du coran ça effectivement
l'état n'a pas le reconnaître c'est sur
le discours sur cette parole il y a un
discours qui est tenu sur la parole
coranique c'est-à-dire par des
intermédiaires et ses intermédiaires là
qui font finalement de la politique et
non pas de la religion eux doivent être
effectivement surveiller en revanche qui
doit être totalement libre
c'est le musulman français le français
musulman doit être citoyen mais le
musulman français la parole religieuse
lui appartient à lui seul le l'état peut
simplement surveiller le discours sur
cette parole faïza comment ça va se
passer comment les les musulmans
peuvent-ils s'organiser aujourd'hui il
ya des initiatives qui sont en train de
naître il ya une plate forme qui a été
lancé notamment via la une consultation
une grande consultation des musulmans
qui a regroupé 27000 vote en ligne et
des dizaines de milliers de témoignages
sur les les opérations terrain sur des
conférences et des équipes de la
consultation des musulmans a recueilli
l'avis des musulmans c'est marwan
muhammad qui fait ça c'est marwan hamed
qui l'a lancé dans cette consultation
mais après marc l'emmène n'est pas seul
on est des dizaines à travailler sur ce
projet depuis plusieurs semaines il sera
annoncé le 30 septembre prochain non est
ce que vous pensez finalement que
réorganiser l'islam peut permettre de
contrer l'islamisme non il ya un
amalgame terrible qu'est en train d'être
fait c'est à dire que j'ai pas
l'impression que l'état veuille dans une
espèce de démarches bienveillante aider
les musulmans à se réorganiser l'état
veut lutter contre le terrorisme
d'accord est ce que ça aurait
organiseront le culte qu'elle va
éradiquer la menace terroriste n'ont pas
servi comme 50% des jeunes musulmans
aujourd'hui qu'ils placent l'islam au
dessus des lois de la république
c'est inquiétant non mais moi ce chiffre
pour moi il vaut rien quand l'institut
montaigne donne un chiffre j'ai lu son
rapport là ça fait trois jours que je
suis dessus en train de lire un rapport
dans lequel on le classifie mois sur les
comptes influents de la sphère internet
en tant que propagandistes
islamistes je sais pas si vous avez
l'impression d'être en danger autour de
cette table quand tu as aidé à côté de
vous - mai mais pour d'autres raisons
mais pour moi c'est un chiffre que je
conteste la rue montaigne je sais pas
sur quoi il se base pour aujourd'hui
définir la menace je ne constitue pas
une menace mans pour mon pays vous êtes
d'accord avec ça ce qu'on essaie de
faire avec l'exécutif ça n'est pas de
lutter contre le terrorisme soyons
clairs main ceux qui sont radicalisées
si vous prenez les profils pour la
plupart ils ne savent pas prié par le
parable fait c'est des gens qui sont
complètement perdus c'est peut-être les
moins musulmans que je connaisse par
contre là où il ya un vrai vrai besoin
aujourd'hui il faut quand même s'en
rendre compte c'est que jusqu'à présent
vous aviez des français de confession
musulmane qui était très lié à la
culture leur pays d'origine qui
apprenaient du coup la religion soit
dans les familles soit moi par exemple
d'origine comorienne c'était dans ce
qu'on appelle des chiffonniers qui sont
un peu les écoles de la vie etc qui vous
permet de savoir un peu d'où vous venez
et c'est bon aujourd'hui il ya une vraie
rupture parce que les jeunes sont
beaucoup moins lié avec le pays
d'origine de leurs parents ce qui est
normal il y aurait dû y avoir une
passation vers d'aller dire les valeurs
françaises la france sauf que vous avez
dans ces quartiers une vraie
ghettoïsation qui fait que ces jeunes ne
se sentent pas français y appartenir la
république du coup vous avez un islam
hors sol qui s'est développée qui
s'appuie juste du coup sûr des versets
ou ce que pense qu'on peut entendre sur
internet et plus de rattachement à
quelque chose qui relève de
l'environnement et du pragmatisme qu'on
peut avoir lorsqu'on est musulman dans
un pays ou dans un autre voilà j'en
madame a l'air de dire que le terrorisme
et l'islam ces paniers en réalité
l'islamisme est quand même lié à l'islam
mais ce qui est important c'est de
lutter contre site cette idéologie qui
est aussi effectivement une culture de
citer on a des islamo racaille qui
connaissent peut-être pas très bien le
le quorum et qu'ils soient
désintégration culturales et qui se
servent effectivement de l'islam pour
pour exprimer leur révolte mais je ne
crois pas que mes cages au provincial a
demandé attendez moi je veux finir ce
n'est pas ce que vous dites un truc qui
me choque si vous écoutez un disque de
led zeppelin ça s'appelle admettons que
ça soit le coran si vous l'écoutez à
l'envers c'est l'islamisme ce n'est plus
les épines qui avait prévu de faire ce
morceau donc une lecture erronée d'une
parole originel y'a pas exact n'a pas de
lecture erronée le coran est un texte un
créé avec des versets qui pose problème
c'est pas nous à nous y'a pas de
réformer le coran de toute manière mais
alain makaba et rosé thématique problème
d'interprétation de l'interrogation n'y
a pas de vatican pour dire quelle est la
bonne interprétation donc il ya un
problème de textes à mon avis on peut
rien faire c'est pas à nous de réformer
l'islam par contre sur le problème de la
désintégration culturel oui on peut
faire un mais ça n'a rien à voir avec
organisé l'islam de france de toute
manière vu le rapport de force si on
organisait il sera immédiatement
noyautée par les plus extrêmes page 2
sur les plus
sûrs les noms mais vous savez pas que
hank plus vous criez - vous êtes
crédibles ont calmé voulait jouer rire
que je suis
extravagant qu'à vous décrédibilisez
qu'elle même si on veut lutter contre
l'extrémisme à mon avis il faut dans les
cités là où il ya des ghettos dans les
mosquées qui pose problème faire le
ménage tout simplement et ça il faut se
servir de l'état régalien avoir le
courage de le faire et ensuite il ya un
tabou qui est celui de l'immigration si
aujourd'hui il ya des ghettos dans
certaines banlieues que je connais bien
parce que j'y ai grandi c'est parce
qu'on n'a pas maîtriser les flux
migratoires et qu'on a laissé se créer
des zones homogènes qui aujourd'hui font
sécession parce qu'elles sont
culturellement plus française donc il
faut mettre le paquet pour casser ces
zones a et stopper une immigration
massive sinon on va ajouter du ghetto
ghetto
jal est victime du mézenc du ménage
avant je vais être victime de rien du
tout parce que c'est pas monsieur des
vécus qui va réorganiser les flammes de
france et encore moins les citer mais
serait organisé des salles de france je
veux faire respecter les lois françaises
mais les rollers françaises elles sont
parfaitement respectées dans une même
dans nos quartiers ou alors votre
partition de jeunes qui est né dans la
cité et qui a vu des filles se faire
égorger en bas des bâtiments qui s'est
fait arracher son pain au chocolat et
tous à d'autres vous n'avez pas venir me
la faire à moi vous allez pas venir nous
raconter ici que les problèmes de
l'islamisation
j'ai pas dit kai pad attentats commencez
pas à venir tourner le
la sécurité ya pas de bien un problème
un problème d'insécurité il n'est pas
que dans nos cités il ya un problème
avec la radical la radicalisation quand
elle devient terroristes ça c'est un
gros problème est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
allez mettre tout sur vous et venez de
faire une espèce de chakchouk à un
mélange de
l'immigration les sites et les filles le
la radicalisation les mosquées
intégrisme et vous vous rendez compte de
ce que vous faites les personnes là vous
allez mais c'est terminé vous racontez
n'importe quoi vous avez vous êtes en
train de participer vous avec la sphère
politico-médiatique avec vous écrit
notamment dans le figaro à angoisser les
gens on peut parler des déserts essayait
fait des frères musulmans c'est bien on
trouve les ccf et les frères musulmans
c'est vous qui fois il suffit de voir
les écrits de marianne manque de
marouane chamakh d'ailleurs votre votre
sondage est votre appel aux musulmans
j'espère qu'il va être public et qu'on
va voir les gens qui s'exprimait ce
qu'ils réclament le 30 septembre arrive
vous êtes veux bien
[Applaudissements]
mais pour hakim el karoui alors hiver
une taxe halal donc qui serait gérée par
l'islam de france donc il serait pas
géré par l'état un peu comme la cacher
route pauvres pour les juifs et avec
l'argent de cette taxe il propose de
former des jeans à mais de construire
des mosquées est ce que ça vous semble
cohérent
mois encore une fois j'aime bien la
laïcité j'aime bien la loi de 1905 donc
je crois que que c'est pas efficace et
qu'il faut aller chercher
les solutions ailleurs en plus je crois
que ça ça traduit un prisme
multicultural et chez makro et chez
hakim el karoui qui est le contraire de
ce qu'il faut faire à qui va encore plus
enfermer les gens dans leur milieu dans
leur culture dans leur religion que
c'est une pente en fait que nos élites
emprunte depuis les années 80 sans le
dire depuis les mouvements antiracistes
qui était différentialiste au lieu
d'être
universaliser je crois que ça n'a pas
fait du bien je vois par exemple dans
les cités moi quand j'étais jeune on le
disait à il faut construire des mosquées
parce que sinon on va avoir les l'islam
des caves la vérité c'est qu'on a
beaucoup de mosquées ont été construits
notamment parce que les élus locaux ont
fait du clientélisme on appelait ça des
centres culturels alors que c'était des
centres cultuel et du coup voilà plus il
ya eu deux mosquées plus aujourd'hui il
ya eu 10 à nice donc si on n'est pas
capable de contrôler ce qui se dit dans
ces mosquées là c'est pas la peine d'en
construire plus en l'état actuel du
rapport de force dans l'islam je suis
pas sûr que ce soit une bonne chose qui
est plus de mosquées en france et très
politiquement correct de le dire mais je
le dis bien alors est ce que cette taxe
halal dont qui servirait à former des
imams à construire des mosquées est ce
que ça vous semble faire quelque chose
de bien non je pense que c'est une
mesure qui est pas du tout pertinent ac
pas applicable en plus aujourd'hui une
artiste plein l'industrie du halal elle
est gérée par des non musulmans j'en
passe qui viendrait aujourd'hui ce qui
nous assure et déjà qu'ils ont envie de
participer à ça et puis c'est le en fait
ce qui est ce qui me dérange c'est ce
qui n'est pas dit derrière cette mesure
aujourd'hui les musulmans il donne pour
leurs mosquées il ya des collègues qui
sont faites de partout pour fonder
construction excusez moi landon les
musulmans doivent bien entendu comme les
catholiques donne pour les églises donne
sans doute plus mais il a quand même de
l'argent carey d'arabie saoudite du
maroc d'algérie de turquie et ça c'est
pas du bon argent dans nos mosquées nom
et qu'on pouvait juger si c'est du bon
argent ou pas quand là bas je sais que
le qatar par exemple c'est un des pays
qui est le plus prosélytes au niveau de
l'islamisme comme de l'argent qatari je
pense pas que ça soit du bon argent pour
la france je veux donner l'exemple de la
mosquée l'institut est mort à nice qui
est abritée est hébergé dans un local un
bâtiment qui appartient au ministre des
cultes saoudien il en a fait don à
l'association ce ministre des cultes
saoudien n'a jamais mis les pieds dans
sa mosquée et le discours qui est tenu
et un discours plutôt de rite malikite
donc par animal maghrébin c'est pas à
l'islam wahhabite qui est tenu ça veut
pas dire il n'y a aucune c'est très
intéressant ce que vous dites et la vie
saoudite peut financer une mosquée sans
que l'islam professé dans la mosquée
soir wahhabite
absolument si je peux te permettre son
respect financement moi je suis partisan
du fait que le financement étranger de
pays étrangers devraient être interdites
c'est aux musulmans de france
d'organiser la construction de lieux de
culte leur propre argent ça c'est une
question qu'il faut se poser moi
j'aimerais quand même revenir un peu sur
ce que l'entente du but alors parce que
j'ai cru voir abandonner la marine le
pen surgir
c'est typique en fait de ce que
j'entendis pilier graisser les
numériques de persuader les léonards et
pas pour des bacs ont du mal à mais
j'essaie de le faire si vous me laissez
parler ont du mal à concevoir qu'on
puisse être français et musulman qu'on
puisse être voilées et française qu'on
puisse être député et ce après said donc
moi je vous le dis très honnêtement
quand j'ai commencé à leur dire non non
non mais honnêtement il faut dire aux
musulmans qui faisait valoir les
vétérans et les coûts des membres c'est
ce qui se fait dans ses mains il n'y a
aucun danger points lorsque vous avez
dans deux mois je vais je suis élu sur
les quartiers nord de marseille lorsque
vous avez autant de personnes ghettoïser
la moitié de la ville 300 400 mille
personnes dans des quartiers où vous
avez un bus qui passait encore quand il
nage pas quand tu peux pas vraiment
personne bouge tout ça est un phénomène
sociétal c'est la société ce sont les
élus qui ont fait en sorte qu'à un
moment donné vous avez une partie de la
population qui a été théorisé sur une
partie de la ville et c'est le cas dans
énormément de quartier et pourtant vous
avez encore des français j'en fais
partie qui souhaite que tout simplement
appartenir à la république voilà donc
moi ce que j'ai aujourd'hui c'est que
des discours comme ça je plaisante ans
et je fais un temps parce que vous
n'êtes pas légitime pour le faire
pourquoi j'avais légitime vous savez
qu'on connaissait rien pourquoi j'ai mal
je suis avec 500 noms mais consisterait
à ces corps que vous avez grandi non oui
parce que ses cartes mais oui mais
j'avais rendez vous avec sa finesse sur
scène j'ai fait toute ma scolarité à
saint geniez ensuite à paris 8 à samedi
et dont vous voyez vous allez devoir
être vil sujet ouais c'est pas moi qui
suis raciste et vous en l'occurrence
puisque vous me juger à ma couleur c'est
pas un costard à outils de la pêche du
gard où est ce que vous dites moi je
vois ses racines j'ai parlé va-tout
exacte n'a pas été un peu limite et
migration n'est pas la cause de tous les
problèmes nous avait dit que c'était la
cause de
marseille et le trouver un métier où je
verrai à des combines a pas d'étranger
il n'y a que des français dans ces
quartiers-là volant vers gaza il ya des
concentrations arrêter de parler de
vague d'émigration vous êtes ridicules
mais je veux édicules je ne suis pas
ridicule les français ne trouve pas
ridicule ils savent vous pouvez leur
raconter ce que vous voulez ils ont
aussi augmenté dans ces quartiers la
libération est responsable de tout mais
vous avez reconnaître vous même dans les
dunes vous avez reconnu vous même qui
avaient des concentrations de population
et ensuite votre discours victimaire
d'or sur votre discours victimaire votre
est tombé vous prétendez vouloir donner
aux jeunes l'envié d'être français et
moi je vous rejoins je suis pour la
transmission de la culture française je
suis fils des deux d'étrangers et petit
fils d'étrangers et on m'a transmis
l'amour de la france et la culture et
joseph leroy retrouve la direction cet
italien je réclame la même chose pour
les autres blocs mais simplement on m'a
pas expliqué que la france était
méchante est responsable de tout laon en
faisant un discours victimaire comme
vous faites en expliquant que la
république est coupable de tout nous
tous les problèmes sociaux et des
problèmes d'intégration vous nourrissez
une forme de ressentiment et vous faites
quelque chose voilà de de pas très net
une forme de clientélisme et lorenzo
comptait bien dernier point je pense que
ça va vous mettre d'accord dernier point
faut-il apprendre l'arabe à l'école cei
non la question c'est pas c'est pas
d'apprendre l'arabe c'est de savoir
comment est ce que la religion est
enseigné la religion va pas on va pas
d'apprendre à l'école donc il faut se
poser la question de savoir comment est
ce que on peut aider les musulmans à
faire en sorte que cette religion soit
enseignée et bien enseigner et là dessus
c'est là où l'état un rôle quand même
pour dire bien sûr parce qu'on ne n'est
pas inné je ne sais pas inné de dire que
voilà ce que c'est que la république ce
que c'est pas donc il faut aussi la
prendre ceux qui enseignent et donc la
république peut valablement dire à ceux
qui enseignent pour voilà ce qui peut
être ce qui permit ce qu'il n'est pas et
après à vous de vous organiser
avec notamment peut-être le financement
du halal ou peu importe pour financer ce
tu pourras enseigne à ses lacets jaunes
le fait déjà la rendait à l'école moi
c'est pas quelque chose qui va me
déranger en soit que leur absence
enseigne à l'école mais ce qui est un
but derrière cette cette proposition
c'est que dans les mosquées il y aurait
des discours qui sont tenues qui sont
sous-jacents et qui leur sont dispensés
pendant les combats a complètement faux
mais je me souviens d'un imam qui
expliquait que si on écoutait de la
musique en stream soir mon rêve en
cochon je pense qu'il fait l'imam de
brest il s'est expliqué ce contexte les
avalanches ton port
non mais s'expliquer sur le sujet après
jeu comme fers l'avocate de donner ce
que les uns et les autres mais je veux
dire c'est que sur le sujet est aussi
con de dire que dans les mosquées c'est
formidable on apprend que des bonnes
choses que de dire on apprend que des
mauvaises choses est ce que c'est cette
phrase a été prononcée pendant un cours
d'arabe je crois pas alexandre avait
l'école d'abord il faut savoir que ça
existe notamment maire s'est proposé
depuis très longtemps depuis les années
70 ensuite dans le secondaire des
classes concernées mais effectivement
parce que les enfants se sont tournés
vers l'arabe pour annick des mosquées
plutôt que vers l'arabe littéraire donc
moi ce que je pense que la priorité
c'est quand même d'apprendre le français
en primaire justement pour éviter une
partition communautariste delà de la
société et ensuite si on considère comme
hakim el karoui qui a un problème dans
les mosquées ou du moins dans un certain
nombre de mosquées eh bien il faut
fermer les mosquées
il à faire respecter la loi c'est aussi
simple que ça garde un bon pour finir
les débatteurs ici qui ont tous leurs
points de vue sont tous vous jouez vous
prisonnier de ce qu'ils pensent être
leur identité on verra toujours un
musulman venir défendre la cause des
musulmans un blanc mâles hétérosexuels
et c'est un avenir défend je donnais des
mais vainement il ya malheureusement la
cause de l'ia malheureusement une des
maladies française c'est de tout lire et
ses combats et ses revendications par le
prisme de sa naissance et son origine et
ses skis toujours me rendre malheureux
dans ce pays
[Musique]
oui
j'avais moi même énergie de la veille
[Musique]
avec notamment soir
rachita dont nous saluons le souvenir
ici ce soir iad merci d'avoir été avec
nous aussi
on se retrouve entre la vue pour la
suite
[Musique]
il
vous permet de savoir quel jour on est
là on a put est toujours avec moi les
champions d'asie
michel
quand il fait ça il le faisait déjà dans
tout le monde en parle d'image il vous a
dit ça va
très vite paris fait pas bizarre d'être
sur un siège fixe non ça va
il va vivre ce temps pour moi donc zazie
vous quittez de voice qu'est-ce qu'il
avait plus vous manqué le fauteuil qui
tourne les pantalons les arts de florent
pagny ou de faire croire à des chanteurs
qui vont devenir célèbre
pas malin qui deviennent célèbres
mannequins agite ses bras la vega le
cargo gas et c'est là donc ça a beaucoup
qui se suicident aux yeux alors on va
parler d'autres nouvel album c'est là
l'essentiel le premier single qui
s'appelle speed en mai à 3 millions de
vues
[Applaudissements]
comédien guillaume canet j'ai découvert
cette photo en préparant les missions
vous allez retrouver vos kouyou pas vrai
j'ai encore mal un grand pas ce cap à
l'accueil mais
au muscle adducteur à l'adducteur parce
que dans le film qui vous amène avec
michel fau il en faut des couilles ça
s'appelle l'amour est une fête ça se
passe dans l'univers du porno des années
80 en fait ça aurait pu s'appeler des
petits mouchoirs
mais bon
d'accord il vous michel fau alors
disons que je connaissais pas
les
comédiens exceptionnels tout peut
absolument tout jouer même les comédiens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
leur temps c'est l'heure des infos de
vise haut
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai dit bonjour laurent on
jouera chose je descends de mieux en
mieux l'escalier en fin d'année en année
je me jette
[Musique]
et on va commencer les infos cette
semaine par le souvenir cette semaine il
y a dix sept ans le souvenir des
attentats du 11 septembre c'était mardi
dernier 17 ans et malgré tout on se
souvient tous du où on était ce 11
septembre 2011 tous sauf jacques chirac
évidemment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez on y va pour la politique
française
marcherait mieux vaut mieux ne pas faire
affaire bénard à bfm tv diffuse la fiche
de paye et le contrat d'alexandre banana
à l'elysée on apprend qu'il gagnait
7113 euros par mois on n'avait pas vu un
arabe aussi bien payé pour mettre des
coups de boule depuis zinedine zidane
ouais
alors c'est vrai c'est bien p7100 13
euros par mois mais pour finir pour un
mec qui était à la fois gardes du corps
crs bagagistes agent secret et catcheur
semi-professionnels ces cadeaux dont la
série entourage du président le poste de
porte parole de l'elysée occupé par
bruno roger-petit va être supprimée
alors c'est cet ancien journaliste qui
avait tellement les schémas con pendant
la campagne qu'il a été obligé de lui
inventer un poste de porte-parole muet
en
tout cas si vous chez vous vous sentez
inutile dans la vie pensez à bruno
roger-petit après vous vous sentirez
beaucoup plus
la polémique de la semaine
l'école jean michel blanquer revue
redonner du prestige à la langue arabe
oui bah c'est vrai que une langue parlée
par 350 millions de personnes dans le
monde elle attendait jean michel
blanquer pour qu'on lui redonne un petit
peu de prestige
l'idée de pouvoir apprendre à l'école
l'arabe comme on apprend le russe ou le
chinois et lance un choix alors là
extrême droite ils se sont emballées
réveillère des cours d'arabe obligatoire
à nos enfants m'ont tous parlaient arabe
et c'est quand même marrant de se rendre
compte que les premiers à gueuler c'est
ce qui en 40 auraient été les premiers à
prendre de l'allemand
[Applaudissements]
et d'un ministre à l'autre marlène
schiappa à présent le porno sur internet
ça évidemment ça touche tout le monde et
elle va exiger la mise en place de
filtres pour empêcher les enfants d'y
accéder
la difficulté vivant c'est de savoir
quel filtre par mois j'ai testé avec un
filtre snapshot bon ben voilà c'est
ouais c'est ça marche pas hyper bien ses
volets chapal se dit je vais envoyer des
images qui vont s'afficher la marlène
ses deux fils très très très bon mais
c'est pas mal des images vont s'afficher
dès qu'un mineur veut se connecter sur
un site porno pour le dissuader d'aller
plus loin et c'est pas mal comme il est
là en exclusivité
j'ai ces images donc la première qui va
s'afficher pouf si tu cliques sur ce
site géré venir chez toi et si vraiment
ils osent aller plus loin là vraiment
c'est impossible avec une image suivante
si tu glisses
là vraiment c'est
marlène ci-après toujours mais sur un
tout autre dossier elle veut plus de
père dans les réunions parents profs et
elle s'est fendu de deux tweets pour
dénoncer la faible représentation des
papes alors le premier c'est celui-ci
réunion parents-profs de rentrée au
collège 27 merci père hashtag maman
travaille hashtag où sont les hommes
suivi d'un deuxième tweet vraiment elle
dit onze ans que je fais des réunions de
parents onze ans que je compte onze ans
que chaque année les sommes sont ultra
minoritaires oui mais marlène si ça fait
onze ans que tu vas toi aux réunions de
parents qu'est ce qu'il fout monsieur
schiappa de vie rongeurs mais
quand le féminisme c'est comme le porno
pour mettre le bon filles allaient
féminisme vrai féminisme cette fois le
journaliste franck ballanger mari de
roxana maracineanu la nouvelle ministre
des sports ne couvrira plus les sports
pour cause de conflit d'intérêts si
seulement macron avait nommé la femme de
pascal praud ça nous aurait beaucoup de
bien à tous
les judiciaire
agression au couteau à paris on l'a
fusillé avec des boules de pétanque
c'était cette semaine sept personnes
blessées au couteau le long du canal de
l'ourcq l'homme d'origine afghane a été
interpellé grâce à un joueur de pétanque
tueur c'est une moule en pleine tête les
français ne faut pas les faire chier je
peux vous dire mais surtout c'est quand
même le summum de l'humiliation pour un
musulman de servir de cochonnet
[Applaudissements]
médias frédéric lopez kit rendez vous en
terre inconnue et à voir la tête de
certains quand ils ont appris l'info je
peux vous dire ce n'était pas facile
alors là les mursi d'ethiopie faut une
gueule jusque par terre et c'est
vraiment bête qu'il arrête on aurait
tous rêvé de voir didier deschamps dans
l'émission la tête qu'il aurait fait
quand il aurait appris qu'on l'emmenait
chez le dentiste
champion du monde toujours le capitaine
des bleus hugo loris condamné pour
conduite en état d'ivresse à l'ombre une
suspension de permis de 20 mois et 50
mille livres d'amandes en apprenant la
nouvelle franck ribéry aurait déclaré
cinquante mille livres déjà tu m'en
donnes un je me sens largement puni
top facile mais on la prend quand même
aller les brèves
mergerac ivre il saute du 7e étage et
atterri sur le toit d'une supérette et
celle là sauvé sa la sauve et morale de
l'histoire c'est l'absence du commerce
de proximité qui a tué mike brand
[Applaudissements]
canada et ça ça va parler à tous les
jeunes étudiants dans le public pour la
retrouver il envoie un mail aux 246
nicole de son université il fait un peu
le gros lourd mais en fait il a écrit un
mail avec comme titre je t'ai rencontré
la nuit dernière tu m'as donné un
mauvais numéro et oui et donc il s'est
pas posé la question de voir pourquoi
elle lui avait donné un mauvais numéro
et si c'est le cas vous pouviez de
bonnes chances qu'elle s'appelle pas
nicole non plus mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a dernière c'est peut-être ma
préférée de la semaine en italie la
maquette du nouveau pont de gênes se
brise et s'effondre devant la presse
c'est vrai si l'inventer aurait été
exagéré de ma part quand ça veut pas ça
veut pas et on a une réaction de
l'architecte françois pignon qui dit je
ne comprends pas j'avais pourtant
calculer l'angle entre les allumettes au
millimètre
culture
et cette semaine on quitte l'art moderne
que j'aime bien pour aller vers un
classique l'un des plus grands peintres
de l'histoire exposé dès le 21 septembre
au musée jacquemart andré à paris le
caravage michelangelo merisi da
caravaggio je sais que vous aimez
beaucoup dit le caravage peintre
milanais de la fin du xvième siècle qui
a révolutionné le clair obscur on va
avoir quelques heures qui vous donneront
peut-être envie notamment celle ci où
l'on voit michel onfray écrivant des
mémoires posthumes après 657 passage
télé 12400 conférence qu'être infarctus
et 6 avc et ensuite ce tableau ce
tableau dont l'attribution caravage fait
débat mais peu importe on reconnaît très
bien aymeric caron en train de tomber
amoureux
est ce si ceci voilà je suis là et très
très mignon évidemment et il démontre ce
jeu clichés d'enfants ont dit les anges
n'ont pas de sexe c'est pas vrai non les
anges ont une petite [__] c'est très
différent
[Applaudissements]
et il a également peint des gens de son
époque notamment voilà ici un portrait
du pape paul iv est très beau alors
quand on l'observé comme ça on voit le
visage de l'homme on retient beaucoup de
détresse qu'est ce qui nous dit alors je
crois que j'ai un début de réponse il
nous dit ceci ok mes parents n'avaient
pas beaucoup d'argent mais de là à
refiler les vêtements de ma grande soeur
[__] et également des gens de notre
époque loin des polémiques asia argento
qui retrouve la sérénité au bras de son
nouvel amant les terminaux par cette
offre thierry la diseuse de bonne
aventure du caravage qui a inspiré
quelques années plus tard bartolomeo
manfredi avec la diseuse de bonne
aventure égyptien voyez c'est très très
bas de tableau non mais je trouve qu'il
ressemble un people le type à gauche là
et c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'il me
ressemble un petit peu alors écoutez on
va voir ce qu'il y pour vérifier si
c'est moi tu es très drôle tu vas être
augmenté
jeudi à la semaine prochaine et bonne
visite parce que l'art c'est comme la
politique c'est pas parce qu'on n'y
comprend rien
tiens
motion sur scène à paris et dans toute
la france
et non maintenant c'est l'heure de la
promo qui s'affiche c'est shopping
voilà parce qu'un artiste c'est aussi un
code-barres c'est comme super mercier
s'est dit choqué
[Musique]
alors asie après une absence de trois
ans dans les bacs pour pouvoir assurer
votre tournée votre rôle de coach dans
de voice vous revenez avec votre dixième
album sur la licencier avec un c réalisé
par edith fabre une wii allait bien oui
alors vous dites on a joué la carte de
l'électrique de l'aquatic et du feu de
bois c'est à dire quoi j'ai dit ça bah
ouais c'est comme à dire comme fui ces
combats non on a passé un temps infini à
faire cet album mais joyeux voilà c'est
plus des premiers cas bon quand même
ouais j'avais déjà un peu mis un petit
peu d'électro dont tout le monde il est
beau dans des chansons comme ça même la
loupe je suis un homme c'était un
simple mais oui c'est bien on sait pas
s'interdire des trucs un peu trop
d'électro là tu trouves non je pose la
question
réussi à une fois que j'appelle rugby
donc il ya 3 millions de vues sur
youtube qui est très gonflé parce que
c'est une accélération des changements
de tempo c'est un peu un rythme
exponentiel
j'ai un peu comme un coeur qui
s'accélère oui après ces fameux kit
arctic gardens voilà exactement voilà
oui c'est ça et l'album s'appelle
défibrillateur là
c'est pas un principe qu'on a inventé un
chalenge extrait dit il tant de trading
twilight l'automne dernier voilà ça
commence très lentement et ça se termine
très rap la chenille qui redémarre
les références alors il ya aussi les
mots parce que un choeur flambant vieux
pour qui il est désormais temps de
quitter ce corps sage si tu vas pas bien
écrit 3 millions de vues je les ai déjà
dit deux fois on regarde donc ça fait 6
millions pour le coup je tiens on
regarde très vite à quoi ma news j'ai dû
faire ça magnéto serge hivert venu
certes magnéto serge
debout à l'essor
tous sont bas
x
[Musique]
je ne
flaubert
tu suis cours
tu fais
beaucoup
faites tout
[Musique]
et pas
est ce qu'on a fait
des
centaines
mais ça c'est trop lucide est le
deuxième single jean agissent avec
waterloo non ah ben non c'est quoi
mystère non waterloo parce que le 13
novembre 2015 et chercher votre fille ou
cirque et en rentrant de ton scooter
vous passez de vol à la bonne bière 15
secondes après la fusillade c'est un
silence de mort et au loin on entend les
coups de feu au petit cambodge et votre
fille s'évanouit pas forcément en
veillant n'était pas destiné à vivre une
zone de guerre après la chanson waterloo
et pas d'ailleurs elle se serait appelée
autrement elle se serait appelée
bataclan c'est vraiment voilà un autre
d'un traumatisme
voilà fait quelque chose d'un peu plus
génériques nous appelle la violence des
hommes et d'humanité ce bel waterloo
mais s'il est belle
le
oh
bien
effectivement une dimension électro qui
n'est pas nouvelle mais qui est très
présent et votre voix vous la voix
éraillée j'adore on dirait on dirait
monica vitti
fumer des cigarettes
j'ai découvert cette voix un peu
éraillée il ya longtemps où je suis je
fais même pas à l'époque mais
quand on pousse la voie en fait
sarkozy tu es sur le décor noir
et c'est extrêmement sexy cette voie je
vois ce machin truc j'ai pas dit ça
il ya des chansons comme dans scène
comme dans petroleum qui promeut
l'écologie oui ça me tient peu à coeur
je pense que quand on a des enfants on
essaie de se dire peuvent on les a mis
au monde et que ce serait bien que la
gueule du monde reste à peu près
plausible un peu de chance mais bon on
peut essayer si si on peut y arriver
vous fabriquer vous même votre lessive
entre autres à éviter les trucs demeurer
y arrive pas ça symbole pas comment vous
faites la russie dans une casserole ou
d'humilier arbitres carbonate de soude
écoute lors
comment on fait de l'année 6 mai
carbonate de soude cristaux de soude
savon de marseille qu'est-ce qu'il
yad'autres du savon noir un peu
l'essentiel à la fin de l'eau on fait
bouillir ça dure une minute plus de
contenants plastiques à pouvoir
l'appliquer à citer quand on sait que ça
ne l'est elle même son shampoing
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gelée marion cotillard guillaume canet
vous faites votre lessive non non non
non mais il ya un vrai lien où il avait
des toilettes sèches
et vous faites votre compost vous même à
ça qu'on pousse mais voilà certains boss
a tout à fait ça sent la merde dans le
jardin c'est là ça c'est la vie
le palier des 10 heures le temps de
promouvoir votre album essentiel sur les
routes puisque vous quittez donc le jury
de den bosch
vous avez réalisé en fait qu'à un moment
vous étiez plus connus de dos que deux
fasse don vous a dit il faut que
j'arrête par les talents oui sûrement
enfin gagné aussi annoncé son départ est
ce que vous savez s'il avait aussi une
adresse pour les impôts
j'en sais rien il ya aussi pascal obispo
qui s'en va il y avait une embrouille
avec lui aucune parce que partout où il
ya écrit que oui alors à chaque saison
il ya des embrouilles jouons un stick
alors qu'est ce qu'il y avait une année
alors une année jennifer pouvais pas me
saquer alors que de vraies c'est
vraiment fait appel notre code
l'année d'après c'était j'avais poussé
la vaysse 2000 caf et c'est bien je
trouvais un train c'est bon j'ai peu
crédible que f 2000 cas alors vous être
remplacé donc pas julien clerc jennifer
soprano est ce que quelqu'un a dit à
julien clerc que ce prénom n'était pas
le chauffeur de ça
je sais pas je ne réponds pas c'est bien
beau lui demandera j'imagine qu'il va
venir nous en parler reste 1000 cas oui
vous en aviez marre d'entendre j'adore
ton voix parce que là c'est un peu jane
birkin quand mamie annonce a dormi car
c'est quelqu'un de cultivé de
sophistiqué d'intelligent de deux traits
enfantins aussi à ce côté maturité qui
côtoie vous les jambes sur wii les
charmants alors dernière question la
note notre liste qu'est-ce que emmanuel
macron vous plaît
pourquoi cette question vous allez voir
que c'est à surprises alors
en tant que président en tant qu'homme
comme bon il est pas désagréable et
bégayant il est plutôt moins vieux que
les autres mais plutôt beau gosse non
parce que je me sens parce que
mitterrand et sarkozy
s'était pas votre came
bas j'étais là je me suis pas posé la
question mais je crois que j'étais moi
je voulais poser la question ah oui non
mais ce lundi et au surf tu serais -
françois mitterrand pour combien
bassil arrêter d'être président ouais du
milf ont cent mille noms 1 milliard mais
non ça se monnaye pas ça enfin voyons un
milliard de milliards d'années pas
question milliards de milliards de
milliards de milliards maintenant lui et
moi sur une île déserte je préfère me
faire un dauphin
finale en asie ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que votre liaison avec nicolas sarkozy
ça n'a pas eu tellement de conséquences
sur votre carrière ça je vous laisse les
jurassiens ont tout de suite c'est
injouable même pas en rêve même à 10 ans
maintenant plus à nos jeux sociaux
non je préfère lui mois sur une île
dessert je préfère me faire un dauphin
croissance
et la question
maquereau ou un dauphin alors pas été je
suis me préfère me teins dauphin non
mais peut-être que ton cliffs et de
bezeq des dauphins
confluent peur non mais ni l'un ni
l'autre enfin je sais pas bon moi j'ai
grandi un peu pardon un genre t'es pas
obligé de répondre aux questions qu'on
de l'animateur
des salles
et
[Musique]
ramon chante et à miami roja bienvenue
dans les missions qui nous permet de
savoir quel jour on est en compagnie de
zazie
m
michel fau et dolan
et maintenant c'est l'heure de la
rediffuse
[Musique]
alors en hommage au film de guillaume
canet et de michel fau qui se déroule
dans le milieu du porno au début des
années 80 on va faire un hardi quizz
spécial sexe
[Musique]
et le gagnant ou la gagnante aura droit
à un hommage promotionnelle fait partir
y arrive attention on se concentre
quelle est la particularité de la tribu
australienne des walis bris
les garçons doivent se dépuceler avec
les anciennes du village tout le monde
couche avec tout le monde quel que soit
l'âge ou le sexe les femmes épouses tous
les frères d'une même famille où les
hommes se servent le sexe pour se dire
bonjour
alors les femmes et vous avez des buzzer
agents
[Musique]
non non non alors moi j'aime bien l'idée
qui se disent bonjour ouais c'est génial
de ses rangs le sexe margot guillaume
canet
alors dans une étude réalisée par
l'université de londres
quelle chanson est la plus
aphrodisiaques le boléro de ravel
sonate au clair de lune de beethoven
vous
on levée du corps c'est pas mal
chevaucher des châssis légèrement
ou speed 2
[Musique]
et
c'est déjà beaucoup
c'est boléro de ravel ouais tu fais un
cadeau
c'est la cadence
il fallut bon coeur alors qui a
découvert le point g le docteur
grafstein le docteur grafenberg le
docteur graphène ski ou indiana jones
ouais bravo
à gilles collègue allemand tandis que
vincent en 1950 cet homme en quoi
consiste la pratique du baiser indien
michel
louche et quand on embrasse son
partenaire
embrasser son partenaire après une
fellation avec éjaculation pratiquer une
auto fellation ou luchier les orteils
enduit de curry très épicé de
pratiquer une fellation non au revoir
c'est son partenon michel fois
qu'elle spermicide insolite certaines
américaine utilisée telle dans les
années 50 le beurre de cacahuètes le
ketchup le sirop d'érable ou le coca
cola
et que des douches vaginales avec du
coca cola mais rien ne prouve
l'efficacité pas c'est dégueulasse ouais
et s'est échappé du pepsi tomber
enceinte sous
quelle est la particularité de jonah
falcone il a le plus grand pénis du
monde il peut 7,4 testicules il a ouvert
une école de kiné d'un gus et son sexe a
servi pour mouler les capotes du rex /
beau gosse
cyril a ouvert une école cunnilingus non
michel il a le pénis le plus grand du
monde bien sûr
bien sûr mission 25 cm au repos 35 cm en
érection c'est un ami john a c'est un
ami il a été arrêté à l'aéroport de san
francisco en juillet 2012 pour cause
deux paquets suspects
macro est très intéressé par le sujet
emmanuel macron est très intéressé par
la taille du pénis on regarde magnéto
serge téléprotection particulier le mcr
vu remporter un magasin macao avec 2,54
[Applaudissements]
moi je dis rien mais ça laisse rêveur
tu vois pas qu'est ce que le café
d'amour cette boisson aphrodisiaques
fabriqués dans certaines régions
reculées du brésil un café avec une
petite noisette de sperme un café avec
quelques gouttes de sang un café filtré
à travers une culotte porter rang café
préparé quand christina cordula
[Musique]
la culotte porte et oui bravo
c'est michel final il est bien ce michel
cauet franchement il répond bien
norman on va passer au super banco celui
où seuls d'accord qui va répondre à la
question suivante aura tout gagné et
aura doit au trio attention superbe
encontre
[Musique]
alors d'après une étude scientifique qui
a une vie sexuelle trois fois plus
épanouie que les autres les personnes
qui écoutent du métal les couples qui
possèdent un animal domestique
les filles qui ont un prénom qui finit
en ouganda au muc année
les filles qu'on après donc qu'ils
finissent pas
mais c'est vrai à merde c'est toi qui a
gagné la merde je voulais pas/je désolé
j'ai pas entrés par l'est d'éloges sur
toi qui me met road le michel fau michel
fois bien répondu je vais faire une
halte à michel faou
foulard en soie
il met sur le front oui c'est bien
michel fau que vous retrouvez au cinéma
aux côtés de guillaume canet dans
l'amour est une fête et retrouver aussi
michel fau au théâtre de paris non
fric-frac une pièce pleine de gouaille
qui nous plonge avec humour dans le
paris des années 30 et dans laquelle
michel fau pour une fois n'est pas des
visas enfin bravo
plus grand merci et on reprend le
shopping la promo qui s'affiche
alors guillaume canet et michel forget
et avec gilles lellouche camille ravin
et xavier beauvois la fiche de la mort
où une fête donc de cédric anger or le
pitch vous guillaume et gilles lellouche
dirigeait le miro drôme un peep-show à
pigalle en 1982 un soir des hommes
cagoulés débarque pour tout saccagé vous
êtes ruine est obligé de faire affaire
avec vos rivaux et notamment un certain
maurice vocal interprété par michel fau
et là vous produisez un film porno pour
vous refaire mais en vrai vous êtes deux
flics missionné par bercy pour procéder
à un énorme coup de filet dans le
business du x vous devez faire tomber
vos galles on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble magnéto le ministre exige
qu'on en finisse avec le blanchiment
dans le porno
on a notre vedette maurice vogel pour le
flagrant délit fait affaire avec lui et
vous mais surveillée
le porno c'est le cinéma le plus cool à
feurs
tu veux travailler comme producteur pour
moi
non les partants moi ça vous intéresse
as tu un bon film enfin pas trop bien
parce que le public aime pas ça
si on part sur des petites filles moi je
vous prie sans une demi journée 1 est-ce
que pamela peut aller soit douce avec
toi jeu et bien sûr que tu peux viser
pas mais là tu fais pas ma part que tu
aimes pas
dit ni enfin trouvé un pseudo personne
n'a envie de se faire héberger non c'est
que j'ai divorcé a connu 10 et ma femme
avait peur des rhumes
[Musique]
mais par vas-y la retraite on potes
qu'est ce que tu crois que je vais faire
un break
oh non
s'attendait je tourne non c'est moi qui
produit
si vous loupez votre coup moi j'en
connais qui vont rateront kong
on embarque le clip du film rose et
sérieux qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
prendre des exemples mais c'était pas
prévu ça va se finir ce [__]
[Musique]
c'est qui ça va c'est juste c'est une
photo
on reconnaît bien m'en restait une photo
ça donne
[Musique]
moi j'ai adoré donc déjà c'est très bien
réalisé ensuite vous incarnez avec
gilles deux personnages extrêmement bas
réduit la d écoute let cousin mesure les
joue sa tête mais c'est génial c'est un
sérieux le buzzer insatiable et vous
alors à calais vouloir il a les cheveux
décolorés il fume du crack mais ça je
vais vous féliciter quand même parce que
vous êtes un des rares français qui
prend des risques rock'n'roll nous n'en
parlons pas je vous ai déjà dit à
l'époque ce que j'en pensais las
incroyable et dans un monde comme ça où
tout le monde se regarde et où vous y
avait carrément vous n'avez pas peur
guillaume bravo aux
[Applaudissements]
bouffes toujours évidemment excellent il
ya une scène où vous buvez du champagne
on prend de la coke avec vos copines qui
vous suivent partout vous mangez de la
pâte d'anchois
changement au masters man mais jamais ça
dans des films en france les hyperbare
et c'est génial c'est un grand
réalisateur vrai nom mais c'est vraiment
un bon et dans le fond et dans la forme
alors évidemment c'est une époque bénie
c'est l'époque où il y avait encore des
poils à un moment il ya une fille qui se
fait faire le ticket de métro est permis
puisque tout le monde
ainsi c'est une époque
c'est une époque charnière en fait entre
ces post 68 et avant l'arrivée du sida
va arriver de la vidéo et c'est une
sorte de parenthèse enchantée en fait on
voit des personnages qui sont super
touchant parce qu'ils sont en fait que
c'est la fin d'une ère fin d'une époque
qui est une époque de liberté
d'insouciance de feu rappeler quand même
que c'est une époque aussi où les films
pornos cartonné ça faisait des millions
d'entrées ça avait pignon sur rue les
gens aller en coupe le voir des films
pornos et j'avais aidé quand il rentrait
à la maison ouais mais c'est non mais
n'avait pas du tout le même regard
là-dessus et puis il le faisait aussi
avec ce sentiment aussi de faire
peut-être un jour aussi un du cinéma
traditionnel
xavier beauvois qui peut sérieusement un
autre affaire du lot exceptionnel fait
incroyable qu'il est l'humour de jouer
ce rôle hun sen film que tournait en
pellicule c'est à dire qu'à l'époque
j'avais de la pellicule a aujourd'hui à
la vidéo est sur la vidéo on voit les
verrues on voit les points noirs on voit
tous là l'époque c'était un peu
hamiltonien l'image comme un débile et
surtout une époque des films où les gens
s'amusent est vraiment une joie de vivre
qui était propre aux années 70 aux
années 80 parce que ces tournages en
fait sont des moments de vacances sont
des mondes de plaisir des rapports
sexuels y en a plus en dehors du
tournage que pendant le tournage près de
frais tout à fait ça on a on a rencontré
des acteurs et des actrices porno de
l'époque et qui nous racontent et
qu'effectivement c'était très convivial
très familiale et qu'il y avait c'était
c'était tout à fait normal nous a
raconté d'ailleurs que en fait elle
avait quitté son chéri non pas parce
qu'ils tournaient avec d'autres actrices
mais parce qu'il en avait invité une à
dîner
c'était choquant
non mais il y avait une insouciance et
une joie de vivre absolument incroyable
a dissipé un kamikaze a aussi la fille
dont elle est formée d'un amoureux elle
est magnifique elle est fraîche les
ailes ça gentiment quoi ya pas de vichy
a pas de oui oui puis sont ils sont
comme je disais ils sont tous vraiment
humain et c'est vrai que cédric il a
cette qualité de moi j'avais fait la
prochaine fois je viserai le coeur avec
lui et il a tout de même sur un
personnage comme ça qui était un
serial-killer enfin un gendarme tueur en
série il arrive on arrivait à le rendre
touchant et là tous les personnages sont
attachants ils sont tous quelque part un
peu au départ paumé et ensemble ils font
ils font quelque chose et je trouve ça
assez représentative de la nostalgie
qu'on peut avoir de cette époque là où
on est plus en plus dans une société
aujourd'hui qui se regarde le nombril et
qui est seul où on a des mecs qui font
des films chez eux sur leur ordinateur
et puis des spectateurs qui regardent
les villes en cliquant sur un lien et on
est tous de plus en plus seul dans nos
trucs et la servante à quel point vivre
ensemble c'est quand même assez
important bah oui le dernier cinéma
porno le bv relie vient de vient de
fermer le petit marchand kleenex à côté
énergie de ge est fermée aussi
évidemment alors il ya un an problèmes
que vous risquez d'avoir vivre c'est que
les filles qui jouent dans ces films ne
sont pas présentés comme des victimes
à une époque où on aime bien présente et
toujours les escortent les prostituées
comme des victimes quand il faut que ce
soit triste qu'il faut qu'il ait un
problème etc et ces gens là ont l'air de
vraiment s'amuser de prendre du plaisir
est-ce que c'est politiquement correct
est ce que vous n'avez pas peur de vous
faire emmerder par les féminines non
parce que c'est un témoignage d'une
époque on relate finalement une époque
ccc on va pas mentir si on va pas
transformer la réalité c'était comme ça
et ça raconte pas la période
d'aujourd'hui c'est déjà pas mal de
dérapage sur le tournage tu veux nous en
parler non mes cheveux non mais je peux
dire par exemple que on était persuadé
avec gilles qu'on allait être émoustillé
par par le fait d'être avec des filles
nues sur le plateau et en fait on était
comme deux couillons des gens inscrits
un tacle un peu surpris peur
[Applaudissements]
or michel
vous savez que si vous continuez à
fréquenter cnil a dit obligé de passer
vos vacances au cap ferret elle a
regardé qu'ils avaient péri bah oui vous
savez ça qu'on aime mais j'aime pas les
vacances moi arrête ça tombe bien alors
vous êtes donc au cinéma avec guillaume
canet nous est avant tout un homme de
théâtre
on vous retrouve en ce moment au théâtre
de paris dans le fric frac d'edouard
bourdet que vous mettez en scène
également vous incarnez joe qui est un
délinquant un peu looser ami avec une
prostituée loup joué par julie depardieu
le rôle de arletty en 1936 et la
création de la pièce d'edward bordés et
vous décidez d'arnaqué laspalès qui est
un employé de bijouterie donc déjà ça
promet c'est pas vous qui jouez loulou
n'ont pourtant que vous adorez vous
travestir quand même je suis trop moche
non il fallut de loulou frais qu'elle
soit sexy douay non julie à une évidence
dans ce rôle formidable c'est dur de
passer par les ti en fait elle elle fait
avec le style de la pièce mais sans son
pied dans cette formidable puisque fait
en vous regardant femme quand même à
nistos serge merci non ce que vous me
donnez est immense
c'est la quête de toute une vie et à
travers moi c'est la grande famille du
théâtre que vous honorez et je voudrais
bien sûr remercié madeleine sologne
madeleine situe dans la salle pardon
pardon ce n'est pas mon mot lien ce
n'est pas mon molière non bien sûr c'est
le moyen de toute l'équipe non
travailler on dit en chine
dessau a reculé
je trouve à vos caisses passeur tout le
faut
quel con matures
puma
volcom
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a dit
corps
m
ok
[Musique]
jean
michel fau est un génie soyons zen
alors vite le travestissement fait
partie de l'histoire du théâtre le
kabuki c'est le théâtre élisabéthain et
dès l'antiquité dans les pièces de
plaute et femmes étaient jouées par des
hommes donc c'est pas c'est pas nouveau
et puis après au 19e siècle c'était les
femmes qui jouent et les jeunes hommes
hamlet lorenzaccio ces jeux par des
femmes alors vous reprocher à notre
époque son manque d'extravagance et vous
dites les jeunes comédiens je touche un
peu comme à la télé ou au bureau vous
avez raison non même les vieux aussi
oui il est un peu tout le monde joue un
peu pareil enfin ces sacs alors que je
pense qu'il ya pas un jeu qui est plus
légitime que l'autre il ya des notions
de style mais y'a pas un sujet plus
léger devait aimer canet parce que lui
il y va à fond quand même un oui puis
les lilas il a de l'audace et un boubou
de la fantaisie aussi beaucoup
exactement et il n'est pas très
intelligent
ap les
enfants des enfants alors vous passer
son siège d'un répertoire à l'autre vous
dites n'appartenir à aucune chapelle est
un combat ah oui je me sens un peu seul
mais je pense que c'est albert camus
disait qu'on est toujours seul donc je
pense que c'est le lot de l'artiste mais
en effet mais j'arrive encore à trouver
des producteurs et des comédiens qui
m'accompagne pour faire des spectacles
donc pour l'instant ça va vous avez une
réputation d' avenir un peu dans le
métier ah oui il ya des gens qui ne
supporte pas
mais comme disait sacha guitry être aimé
par tout le monde s'est tramé par
n'importe qui donc a envie d'être aimé
par les vaincus
alors ils pouvaient faire les grosses
têtes
par contre c'est gagnant et brutaux
faire elle peut tout faire vite je suis
dadaïste je suis contre le goût du jour
oui c'était ça les dadaïstes ouais
c'était magnifique ce mouvement dadaïste
et dès qu'ils ont été récupérés dès
qu'ils sont devenus un mouvement
artistique il n'était pas content bien
plus de détails possibles en cavale et
j'ai pas osé les affaires l'europe un
film qui se défoncent à oslo un
[Musique]
amour est une fête
il s'est en salles le 12 nov aps le
temps
alors on termine avec vous l'avez sur le
bout de la langue le blindage
[Musique]
alors le thème du blind test aujourd'hui
c'est le bistouri c'est à dire des
chanteurs et des chanteuses qui ont eu à
faire la chirurgie esthétique c'est en
hommage évidemment à rock'n'roll
évidemment vous aviez vous avez dit j'ai
fait du botox donc j'avais jamais voilà
du bon temps ça devait être très mal
fait parce que je pense qu'il y en a qui
on sent que c'est plutôt bien réussi
mais moi je faisais un peu momifié alors
ça m'a fait cracher ta blanche et mon de
l'anus mais je n'en parle pas par pudeur
[Rires]
rapide et des fous vous jouez tous
contre baffie 1 attention brancher la
guitare ont
entonné les temps morts ouais jacquod ma
basse 1 2 twh à l'entraînement
[Musique]
la
dir weh
n'a rien fait c'est une légende
regardez-la ouais ouais c'est vrai je
suis content d'avoir mis carnaby oui
elle n'a rien fait bon on continue on se
concentre
à côté
fresnoy proche d'en avant guingamp
mois pour zazie un point pour leur avis
vous comptez en régie attention emma
aoued accepte
je t'aime
j'ai peut-être fait une connerie de la m
ben oui y'a rien à rien qu'elle a rien
fait emma
[Musique]
georgi un
portable ta faute tu as menti n'ont rien
fait ils ont rien fait les rangs bogdan
avec shirin année là mais euh je crois
que c'est un problème ils ont une
maladie de jeunes adhérents je pense
qu'ils ont quand même bien défendu mais
ils ont fait de la chirurgie pour
essayer de réparer sa part on voit bien
la charge et réparatrice
humain
[Musique]
c'est
non
m
j'ai manière extravagante
sonny and cher bon attention
emma
[Musique]
oui j'ai pas où sont les femmes pas de
jouer
le schéma
c'est l'endroit quel point c'est
dangereux de s'endormir prête à nîmes ce
rôle
m'a
jugé la russie
le
on va t schip en danger soit passé du
soir
bonsoir
il
les topiaires eu une mauvaise photo et
voilà on se retrouve avec deux derbys
son attention emma et la chaleur
[Musique]
l'importance de mettre une bonne crème
solaire
attention c'est qu'on sent à mon avis
cela parlé à michel fau et m'a
[Musique]
tuer
et maintenant allez on se fait un petit
superbe encore un petit cylindre comme
celui ou celle qui va répondre à la
question suivante aura gagné le blind
test et sera obligé de m'y mets une
célébration de foot je sais quand les
joueurs de foot marque un but ils font
des trucs des dents s'est pas levé père
m'a
promis de me attention je suis par bongo
est mort
[Musique]
ils n'ont rien fait nous sommes déçus
attention se concentre et mal
j'ai dit oui berkshire visage je ne
savais plus comment faire
et oui ah oui ophélie winter
j'ai
à
[Musique]
pour guillaume alors comment ça se passe
au foot quand on gagne pas eu lieu
allez
mais non
[Applaudissements]
du sang du christ
jamais
les jeunes faux
la fille
là tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à faire
cette émission rendez vous demain à 19
heures pour les terriens du dimanche
avec eric zemmour première télé pour son
nouveau lit
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
lardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu